hello and welcome to this video playing
vlok v-log not Egypt okay so I'm doing
for Sicilian and playing offbeat line
here with Bishop d7 dumbsquat the coop
right cheek variation yeah I'd like to
play some Sicilians now and then in them
in the blitz games but I try to play
lines that are not as well known because
I have fun so doubt sir but knowledge
sometimes I just no ideas mostly but I
don't know oldham the theoretical
detailed so going for her scribbling and
set up here comes Knight B 3 yeah this
is often an idea of white and trying to
prevent the trade on deform night a5 as
a move that comes into consideration I
think I go for that if he does not take
I have possibly rook c8 and lightsey
form I mean if he goes back basically I
don't think he wants me to take you can
go to d2 though that is an idea with
course that's also very feasible before
are you going to play before here that
strikes me as odd okay I think I want to
control b5 him or maybe he was
anticipating Queen to before that that's
possible yeah I'm sorry he certainly
never had the idea of playing before he
was mostly covering this in advance the
move night to d5 now is it some part of
this position
I can take him to perform it's not if
I'm going to take I'm just not sure if
creature before is really helping all
that much it is interesting though I
mean maybe I'm actually threatening ship
takes a phone okay I'm threatening that
you for anyway but maybe we should take
say force also and quite okay he has
rukon be one so
yeah of course but I thought that this
is a good ending I'm okay maybe a good
ending is a little bit too much but I
thought it is ok for sure so I can take
on the tool and I think I should've
generating Queens make sense but what I
can do actually I can take a form I just
only now spotted this I was thinking
just five and i'm ok with the structure
but of course i can can just take this
critical this is some hanging porn on a
form ok he might take on these six and
try to play against this okay i think
all the way back I think you should take
now only six and maybe try to play
against my pawns if he m allows me to
play a 5 i'm certainly am I'm certainly
just a pawn up for no particular
compensation okay and so I'm going to
shut this down the main thing is that
now I don't see how he attacks my pawns
after capturing he could have maybe
attacked be seven or six sent here I
don't don't quite see it
I Bishop before maybe was an idea but
you came so i can take and win another
pawn but this is the worst pawn
structure ever so i'm not sure that this
is such a great idea okay g6 maybe as an
idea intending Bishop g7 and then
potentially f5 you are getting those
pawns rolling we should be 4i can
definitely take on a 4mm and then bit
ahead on the clock so it looks quite
okay it's just goes back so I'm
preparing f5 or now of course also just
to take I mean I know ego goes goes this
way I'm here interesting so I can take
and then go for check and GF I i think i
rather do that this looks a bit more
conservative but i think this is this is
also very okay covering the six he will
very likely take only five now no it
doesn't okay then then I'm taking f4 and
just check trade everything down
okay so he didn't capture it yeah I
wonder here if f5 is a move or not i
also have bishop age 3 in this position
I don't think he cannot really move the
rhubarb so probably has to him he moved
the rock up okay he's got King f2 we are
on the on the check on you one okay
maybe I can't just be livin ooo sincere
with the bishop and see what he does
Rock g3 mini know okay Bishop e2
blunders stuff but that's not to do that
I'm not entirely sure what the best way
to play this looks like you can take and
Kobe sugar three I think check okay
that's not that was impossible but now
Bishop f3
he has to go before now i think
b form yeah potentially bishop age 6
even though bishop see one lower cover
it Bishop age six you might have to have
c5 this is something that could be
dangerous the pond could be dangerous
time morning g-good yeah it is a bit
dangerous but still it's a bit too
tempting how so he goes for just
covering it and they're feeling
especially active not sure about this
it's a check on d5 but I think after I'd
have to break this check oh I have to
break this down
check I canceled rolling rolling rolling
he admitted to play for third time Tyler
moves at the end still yeah so he
essentially blundered a pawn in this sir
in this situation you would do them 95
but it still wasn't all that easy
because his son was space advantage it
wasn't held all that much yeah so
grabbing this one and now I think you
should take and not allow this but
looking at the game I'm not entirely
sure i made a mistake here for that
could have played efore here that was
stupid I actually did not appreciate
this move correctly rook c8 is good
however yeah boxy eight is good ok so i
played this not all that well they also
missed this ok wow this is the first
game in this session so maybe it was
jenn mckee a coincidence to me that my
opponent isn't i wasn't graded all that
highest he certainly helped me a little
bit with some of his decisions and yeah
here I was thinking maybe this is more
interesting if I take their c6 that
sounds kind of kind of unclear at first
at least and I wanted to take and and
then grab this this and then cover it
the engine says I'm winning wed ok I
wasn't totally sure during the game at
least I didn't blunder this yeah the way
Adam was played um I got that b5 and I
mean he has to take chat and play this
position and this isn't I mean I
probably should win but it's it's still
some work to do in this line by the way
this line we should be seven it's one of
those sidelines that is basically
unknown and it's not all that terrible I
mean it it looks a little bit strange to
commit this Bishop early on and
objectively it certainly worse than the
night off but it's a kind of move that
if you have a look at it and study some
ideas it's a it's a very decent surprise
weapon that you could imply a
Connecticut applying some games ok guys
thanks for watching